welcome folks thanks for being here
those of you that are here in person
those of you that are here remote thanks
for being here so long time members know
the first question I always ask is who
is hiring we have a smaller room today
in person we have virtual room so not
everyone can say it if you're virtual go
to the job postings channel of NY hack r
or slack you can find that my
hackard.org or we'll put a link in
YouTube to get to that so if you're
virtual tell us you're hiring there does
anyone in the room hiring anyone
where's Noam Ross when we need him he
was always hiring all right so no one's
hiring in here no one's getting a job
today from this Meetup Group unless
someone posted virtually
those of you that are here in this room
the pizza is from Lazarus
so everyone should go to bitly Pizza
poll and vote on the pizza let us know
how it is so some of you are regulars
you know what to do you go there you can
rank it on a five-point scale and this
data is available we provide us a live
feed for anyone to go to it's actually
at nyhackgar.org is a live bar chart
this is a rapid High Velocity data but
it's always being updated we can get
your live feed as Json data if you want
that's not how it is seriously and folks
that are virtual if you got pizza let us
know where it's from if you got
something that's not pizza I don't know
why but if you did let us know where you
got so let us know either in the slack
again that's
nyhacker.slack.com if you need a link
for it you go to nyhacker.org and let us
know where you got it from or you can
just tell us right in YouTube where you
got the the your food from let us know
how you're enjoying yourselves people in
the room there's a bunch of stickers in
the back the more stickers you take the
fewer I take home all right so enjoy the
stickers there's some new ones for you
haven't been you've been in a while
so enjoy the stickers folks all right
um we have next month we have R in
government is the conference our
government conference about both R and
other friends because it's our python
sequel Julia go whatever is open source
in the government we have some past
speakers in the room right now we have a
future speaker where'd you go right
there future speaker and some of you
aren't there uh we have David Shore from
Blue Rose research we have David Meza
from NASA Abigail Haddad from Capital
Technology Group we have Celine stromgen
from the FDA we have Dusty Turner from
the Army it's gonna be a really fun time
lots of good talks we're really excited
we'll be doing ticket giveaways to
someone virtual and someone in the room
so if you're in the room your name's
been entered if you're virtual and you
signed up for the talk you'll be entered
and after the talk we will give away
free tickets to the conference
for anyone who doesn't win a free ticket
if you just want to attend but you want
a discount code you can go to rstats.ai
and use code NY hackr that works for
everybody in the room and it works for
people virtual you get a 20 discount
code using our stats and start NY hack R
that's the code
all right then let's see what else on my
announcement so some of you signed up
for this talk about Taylor Swift
some of you sign up for this talk since
yesterday about mapping in r
so to all you swifties I'm sorry our
speaker canceled very very last minute
but we're going to hope to reschedule
this Taylor Swift talk within the next
few months
thankfully our October speaker was able
to come in and save us and move his talk
up a whole month giving one day's notice
so folks I hope you're I hope hope the
folks at want to see you can and that a
bunch of people don't get excluded
because they couldn't make it because it
was one day's notice but hey sometimes
we have to roll the punches so everyone
a big round of applause for saving us
making this happen everyone please
welcome art
never have
foreign
thank you very much for for coming out
tonight and again apologies if you were
expecting some Swift Taylor Swift stuff
um actually the this talk has been ready
since August so I was able to go at a
moment's notice but I haven't rehearsed
the the patter yet so please please bear
with me so we're talking about
geospatial uh mapping in our tonight and
let me warn you in advance this is so
much fun and so easy to do you will very
quickly go down a rabbit hole like I did
and just trying all sorts of crazy stuff
um
so but hopefully when you leave here
today or when you click away you you'll
learn about the huge strides that have
been made in just the last couple of
years in uh open source GIS whether it's
r or python or anything else the power
that is just right there in your hands
now is just truly amazing and in R
making really cool maps uh and doing
very powerful visualizations is super
easy and we'll demonstrate that by
creating an animated flood inundation
map to see how Rising water levels uh
cover land mass
so who am I well first of all I'm not a
data scientist I'm a retired investment
executive so my job was making bets on
whether the Deutsche Mark would go up
based using other people's money uh or
the Euro I go that back that far before
the euro I do some Consulting for posit
to try and make contacts for them in
financial services
but I do I'm a data science hobbyist a
citizen data science scientist if you
will and you can see the other work I do
on my blog
outsiderdata.net so let's talk about GIS
in the old days this is going back to
the early knots and 90s GIS data was
something civilians couldn't access
right
governments were using this stuff they
had their data sets but they were locked
up and they typically used proprietary
software the most popular one is arcgis
by esri and it's it's a great package of
tools super powerful
and the
data which is has become a geospatial
data standard is something called shape
files so those are still in use today
but what is different today is that you
and I can access all of that stuff so
for instance an example of a modern tool
chain in the open source world would be
is a package nothing to do with r now
called qgis and I I recommend all of you
check that out so S3 is still out there
and again I it's it's a terrific and
very powerful tool but it's a it's a
commercial tool proprietary so you could
pay uh 765 dollars a year for a personal
license for arcgis
or you can just download the Open Source
qgis and do a tremendous amount of cool
stuff with that on the fly so for
prototyping for moving things from one
side to another before I start working
with r i often use qgis
so this so think if you folks are
familiar with uh
uh drawing software or or photo software
you know about which is the open
source version of Photoshop so it's kind
of like that all right so in r in
particular there's a number of packages
you should be familiar with uh and these
are all you know so fresh really it's
just really been in the last five years
that this stuff has become very widely
available so SF and the Terra packages
are from manipulating spatial objects
map tools and leaflet are used for
getting interactive maps and we'll see
that in a minute Ray Shader and we'll
see some examples of that in a minute is
for 3D rendering not just Maps but all
sorts of areas within R and osm data is
a package that lets you go out to open
street maps and get map features
elevator is a package that lets you get
topography so you can do topo maps but
also bathymetry so you can get depths
under water now you use these tools
to access
data sets and again used to be
proprietary you just you couldn't get
them for any money uh
but nowadays there's so much open source
data out there crowdsource data some of
the places that I get my data from is
openstreetmap and you may be familiar
with that there's also open topography
for toppo data the U.S Geological
Service does a really nice job of making
their data sets available very
conveniently to either download or get
programmatically through their their API
but also your Regional or local
government probably has a lot more
publicly available data I saw a
tremendous talk at the posit conference
last week where the city of Chicago
uh you know was very embarrassed because
their property tax analytics were
systematically overestimating the market
value of low value properties and
underestimating the market value of high
value properties and they used linear
Russian models in SPSS and they move
that workflow over to a machine learning
model based in in R
and really you know rectified that
problem so 50 000 lines in proprietary
commercial software SPSS was
systematically making an embarrassing
mistakes they moved the tool chain over
to R but why that's interesting for us
in this talk is it's all available
they've made it all publicly available
you can get all of that data about
Chicago properties that they're using to
make their property tax assessments
freely available online so again a lot
of regional governments are doing a
great job you can probably get the
property tax maps and so forth for your
town
online now as well there's also
lidar scans so you can get uh 3D imaging
that's
programmatically usable
for urban spaces rural spaces whatever
so you can get all the skyscrapers in
New York Chicago wherever you can
download those as geospatial objects and
use those in our so that it's just crazy
how much stuff is out there finding it
is sometimes tough getting exactly the
right file that you want to download is
kind of tough searching these uh public
databases is kind of tough but it's all
out there it's just really amazing now
some of them require uh are still
available at cost for a cost most of
them are free but a lot of those require
an API key
Census Data would be an example
or you need a key so this is just a
quick
uh quick aside you may be tempted if you
save your code in on GitHub or some
repository to type in the key as part of
your your script your code don't do that
right so
um there you can the best practice these
days is to save it in your our
environment file and call it from there
and we're getting a thumbs up there
thank you so important stuff
now let's talk about
uh today's topic so you've this is going
back a few months ago you folks may
remember that uh a dam near kerson in
Ukraine was blown up we don't know who
did it uh as of now and it's tough to
figure out that you can come up with
reasons why both the Russians and the
ukrainians might have wanted to see that
damn blown up but it was a humanitarian
disaster because when dams break as we
saw in Libya last week as well uh people
Downstream have a tough go of it so this
is just the uh the water pouring through
the breach in the dam and everything
Downstream was inundated uh for the next
few days eventually it drained out of
course but not before a tremendous
amount of damage uh had been done
so a real uh nasty thing so what we're
interested in doing is can we model what
happened using geospatial analysis are
and we can we do it in a visually
compelling way so
the answer to that is yes of course so
let's we'll start with magic trick
number one
that is can we visualize the affected
area and again this shows I call it a
magic trick because you can see just how
few lines of code we're doing to
generate this not only that but this is
an interactive map I can drive around
here and we can look at the area we can
zoom in uh but that's just a few lines
of code as you can see all I have is I
just had to describe the you know the
four corners in latitude and longitude
of the area I'm interested in and then
put what they what the leaflet package
calls tiles layer them on top of each
other one is from S3 again those are the
guys that make the commercial arcgis
software but they have a lot of their
stuff that's now freely available as
well so we've got the imagery data from
S3 and then from a data source called
cardodb we have the labels to overlay on
that and so right off you know in terms
of our exploratory analysis we can make
a few observations one is
uh you can see the dam is
right about where my hand is waving
right there because you can see the
swampy areas below and there's the River
delta of the nepro river
and if we zoom in a little bit
see this is all interactive real-time
incredible so there's the dam
running vertically down from just
Upstream of the dam you see a canal and
that's provides I don't know if it's
most but a lot of the fresh water to
Crimea Crimea excuse me so one reason
why the ukrainians might have wanted the
dam to be gone is that it cuts off fresh
water supplies or reduces fresh water
supplies to Crimea you also see those
crop circles there you you're probably
familiar with these these radial
sprinklers
those are all being fed from that
Reservoir Upstream of the dam so this is
an agricultural disaster for the Farms
Upstream of the dam and these swappy
areas Down Below in the you can see
where there's no human features there
are all presumably going to be
underwater now how much gets underwater
is what we'll soon see
now let me introduce the simple features
uh so this again we were just doing
exploratory data analysis there so now
let's start doing the the real work here
we're going to create a spatial object
for all further manipulations this whole
project we're doing here is essentially
building a stack we're doing layers both
visually and programmatically that have
more and more information so we start
out with just a bounding box as it's
called which is the rectangle that we're
interested in in latitude and longitude
and we're going to turn that into a
simple features object which is a type
of spatial object and it's noteworthy
because it includes the the map features
and includes metadata about the map or
the the spatial region that we're
interested in and
this case right here we've just created
an empty shell
it has essentially just the the only
features it has are the corners the
bounding box and it has something called
the CRS geodetic CRS which is the
coordinate reference system and that's
going to be important here later on
um now the cool thing for a nerds like
me is that a simple features object is
just really a data frame with metadata
that means you can manipulate it just
like you do a data frame using your
normal workflow in terms of
um adding columns mutating columns if
you use D plier type stuff so in this
example I just add a couple more data
points to this spatial object a vector
of strings called Corner one corner two
right this is useless and not
particularly interesting but it shows
how easy how you can use regular R
workflow to manipulate these simple
features objects you could also extract
the the simple features
points using your conventional ways of
indexing into Data frames so a lot of
familiar ground already there with those
spatial objects so that was a simple
features object that contains uh the the
data about our Geographic object now
let's introduce another type of
geospatial object in R called a raster
and that's not just proprietary R
there's a lot of things but this is just
a matrix
with a value for each point or pixel if
you will on the map now that value can
be anything we want but for our work
today we're going to get our raster with
each pixel is represented as a number
that that represents the elevation
above sea level of each point on the map
so remember simple features object is a
description of the map while a raster
object is a drawing of the map
but both of these things are geospatial
objects in r that have the same kind of
metadata
so again you can manipulate that Matrix
using the same kind of TR any tools that
you use to work on matrices and are any
techniques you use you can use on the
elevation Matrix but again that it
preserves the metadata so in this case
we've taken the bounding box that we
already established
and used a different package called
elevator which gets
elevation data to retrieve
that elevation data now you have to play
around a little bit with the with the
resolution of the thing
um
and you know how much data you get uh
and you it's a lot of trial and error
but in this case we've retrieved a
matrix that as you can see it by the
dimensions is 1900 1980 by 4560.
and uh
the range the values there at the bottom
are minus 51 so underwater under by 51
meters to a high of 107 meters above sea
level so that's the range and again you
see that CRS there as well and the
extent is again just that those four
corners that we're already familiar with
uh and it shows the resolution shows you
the dimensions of each pixel so all of
that stuff is is pretty
English readable or legible so that's
that's pretty good and again it's just a
matrix that you can manipulate
regularly so again
since that's just a matrix
we can do a quick and dirty plot to see
what that looks like so we just set a
palette color ramp from blue to green
we're not doing any special mapping
software or packages to do this we're
just doing the basic R plot of a matrix
where the color scale that
is intuitively understandable to us and
you can see the latitude and longitude
on the axes and there there's that River
delta uh just expressed as colors uh is
the uh is the elevation
super easy
now there's no elevation data
in that so we're going to introduce a
new package called Ray Shader and this
I'm going to digress for a second about
that because this thing is
the Chisel it's
um
uh a person by the name of Tyler Morgan
wall dropped this like a bomb onto the r
world I know about five years ago maybe
um
and it basically does 3D Ray tracing on
our objects and you can use that on
regular ggplot objects or you can use
that on these geospatial objects like
I've done there on the left showing
topographic map and the sun rising and
falling over that mountain lake with a
different topo map for each day as we go
through so just really fun stuff and
this is where you can go down the rabbit
hole because it takes a long time to get
all this stuff right and then
animate all of that stuff but it's
terrifically fun other people are doing
just beautiful works of art with with
Ray Shader so here's just some more
examples of the kind of graphics people
are doing with Ray Shader and they're
just they're just gorgeous just really
nice stuff you so super powerful you
could spend the rest of your life
figuring out all the things you can do
on that and and Tyler isn't resting on
his Laurels he keeps dropping new
um
versions with new features every couple
of couple of months on this thing it's
pretty incredible now we're not going to
use any of this cool stuff actually
we're going to use one particular
feature of Ray Shader which is its
ability to detect water
uh based on adjacent pixels in the
raster that have the same elevation if
there's a big enough flat area where the
elevation elements in The Matrix are the
same we can tell Ray shaders say that's
water
so here's an example of of again we're
just taking the the raster turning it
into a plain old Matrix and then we're
using some Ray Shader code to add water
and detect water and add that as an
overlay to our to a base map
so and then we plot that so that is the
ray Shader object we've now created
which where that shading is based on the
the ray tracing that uh Ray Shader is
doing and not surprisingly the blue is
everywhere rayshader has detected enough
pixels of the same elevation to call it
water all right now this then is the the
key that unlocks this ability to create
the inundation maps because it's
detecting water uh where everything is
the same but what if we arbitrarily
start changing pixels to be the same as
the pixels around them and rayshader
will falsely
detect that as water although again for
the purposes of flooding maybe it's not
falsely so
um let's build
our our
complete image now so add overlay lets
us add uh to our base Maps so we're
going to add a satellite view as our
first layer on this thing and here again
we're if you look here you can see that
we're getting the that world imagery
from the S3 service like we did at the
beginning of the talk right so
um this is you've already seen this
image so this is now but we're just
using race shaders
functions to create this map but it's
that's all we got here we've just got
the the base image
to as the first layer of the object
now what do we want to do next we want
to we're interested in showing human
presence on here so you can't really see
it at this resolution you can of course
see the grids for the uh the fields but
it's a little tough to see exactly where
the human presence is so one way to do
that is to get roads and overlay them on
there now we're going to get the roads
from open street maps and we're going to
use the open Street osm data
openstreetmap package to get that so we
again we go ahead and retrieve here's
the code to retrieve the road data from
open street maps
and
you know at the end of The Talk The the
GitHub Source will be here so you can if
you want to dig into the particulars of
that but notice the thing to notice here
is what does it return aha you've
already seen this it's another simple
features object which the geometry in
this isn't points like we did when we
created our empty thing it's Lines line
strings and the geometry is just
individual vertices of of the lines to
represent the roads and you see the
bounding box you see the CRS there the
coordinate reference system
and you see the other features in
addition to the geometry so the actual
location of the roads is contained in
that geometry column of the data frame
but there's also the name
of the road as one of the features in
there and then a unique identifier is
just the ID so again it's it's a data
frame that you can manipulate very easy
um now let's go ahead and uh oh point
out one particular gotcha I shouldn't
say it's a big gotcha because it's so
easily fixed but all these simple you're
going to be going out to
different data sources right so you're
going to be pulling roads from here
you're going to be pulling water from
here you're going to be pulling
elevation from here buildings from here
whatever it is you may be using you know
two three or four different data sources
when you start building these layered
Maps what you have to make sure is that
they're all using the same coordinate
reference system now everybody here
knows that there's there's multiple ways
of projecting a curved Planet onto a
flat surface so if you look at a
Robinson Humphrey projection it looks
very different than a Mercator
Projection and we need we don't know or
we can't guarantee that all of our
downloaded data is going to have the
same coordinate reference system there's
hundreds and there's some that try to
fit the whole earth because we know the
Earth isn't perfectly spherical those
are not entirely perfect
um but then there's so there's Regional
coordinate reference systems just for
the Northeast United States there's a
particular CRS you could use so you like
if you're downloading city data from New
York
City you're going to see that Regional
coordinate reference system we need a
way of making them all the same so there
are functions in all these packages to
reproject
one coordinate reference system uh onto
another so that's what we have to do
this is what this coordinate reference
system string looks like inside our
uh
one of our simple features file so it's
a lot of information there the only
thing like I said you just need to make
sure you understand how to use these
transformation or reprojection functions
to make them all the same
and you can extract if you want to turn
make sure a
uses the same CRS as B you can extract
the CRS from B very easily and tell
this to transform it to
transform it to transform a into B so a
lot of stuff there but simple to address
you just have to be aware of that now
remember we said a simple features
object is just a data frame so it turns
out ggplot2 which most of you are
familiar with has a geom for simple
features objects so it understands you
can just feed it the simple features
uh object and ggplot understands it so
let's do a a mapping of those rows that
we just downloaded which again we saw it
had the geometry which were were lined
were lines and the names and unique IDs
so in this case we'll use traditional
ggplot workflow to plot the line file
line object and for each of the
different lines we'll see we'll say
color it according to the openstreetmaps
ID which there's a lot of Roads so we're
going to see a lot of colors there we're
not really that interested in that but
that is using the geom the simple
features geom for ggplot just plotting
that road data so you can explore and
see what you got and it's pretty easy to
see where the River delta
uh uh uh Downstream of the dam is by
where the roads are not so that's going
to be very useful for us to understand
where the air where the areas where the
flooded areas have human habitation
because of the roads there
so now let's generate the road overlay
and we'll generate you'll use that road
file Road object to create another
overlay for ratiator because again we're
building layer on layer on layer we're
going to build a a line overlay users
generate line overlay function and Ray
Shader and turn that into uh an overlay
that we can add to our map so again
we're using a specific function there
generate line overlay now
so let's put the our first two layers
our base map and our roads together and
you can see there all that that that
black area those black lines spidery
lines in this Plot show us where the
roads are now
okay now here's where the cool stuff
really happens so we've talked about
this a little bit already you can set
any height in the elevation Matrix below
the water layer but below that we we
want to say is below water level to zero
so Ray Shader will consider it water so
we could just use typical Matrix
operations to
set any value below X to Zero and then
ratiator will think it's water
now now the order of the overlay matters
right because any subsequent overlay
will completely cover up any overlay
beneath it so we're going to have we
want to make sure the roads are
displayed after the water so we see them
on top of the water even though they're
of course underwater
so here's an example of now what we're
doing what we've done is we've in this
example
there's the first one where the water we
haven't done anything to the elevation
Matrix
so that's what is or what is typically
water and in the one below we've just
arbitrarily said if the elevation is
less than or equal to 5 meters
set it to zero
and then Ray Shader thinks it's water so
now we can see what five meters of
flooding looks like
super easy
super cool
now at this point I want to raise some
caveats because this is a dramatization
all right I wouldn't I wouldn't submit
this this would be fake news if I said
this is what the flooding was right
we're simulating it we're modeling it
and there's there's caveats there we
don't know exactly how the water
affected each area at what time
presumably when the dam broke the areas
closest to the dam got flooded first and
the area is farther Downstream flooded
last and maybe less we don't know what
the peak inundation level was for each
area and now of course the water has
receded so again it's while I think this
does give an accurate idea of how tragic
this thing was it doesn't we can't say
this is exactly what happened
so now
we've already what we've done already is
cool enough I think because we were able
to uh animate this stuff but now we're
going to get even
cooler and we're gonna plot the rising
water level as an animation
so again you don't have to go through
this code line by line it's all online
but basically we're going to do these
plots that you already saw
but we're going to Loop through
different water levels and save them as
individual frames individual images on
on uh on our hard drive so we're saving
individual
We're looping through the rising water
levels and saving each one as a frame
and
then we're gonna I'm gonna overlay an
annotated scale I didn't want to bog
bogie down in in
two dense code here it was just me
playing around
so again you can see that if you want
but this is the uh this is the code that
actually puts the frames together as a
gif file I don't know whether you folks
like to call it gif or a gif I call it
gif but
um anyway so what you have though is
just look at the different steps on this
it's very straightforward
is first we resize each frame to be uh
more manageable a little smaller then we
morph it so that it has three so it kind
of morphs from one frame into another so
it's less jerky when it when it uh flips
to the next frame then we say image
animate and then image right so this is
all using the magic package which is a
super powerful uh image manipulator but
again it's all programmatic stuff and it
uses the uh
code from ffmpeg package so but magic if
you work with that you can find it it's
incredibly powerful all right so
here's the finished product
so
see that that green legend in the on the
side is uh is it was the little
decoration I did again I spent so many
so much time just trying to get that
little inset there and it doesn't add
all that much but again you can see this
is a very compelling and dramatic way of
seeing how that those flood waters are
rising up and you can see those Road
areas where there's human habitation
that got underwater and you know like I
said it was a grammatization but we do
know that there were lots of populated
areas there that got flooded when that
when that dam broke
um
so the south side of the river was
generally the swampiest that big dense
area kind of in the uh in the upper half
on the middle that's the city of
Harrison which is fortunately a little
higher elevation
so again
um terrifically powerful stuff and
again it's very simple and
understandable once you start working
with it because you're doing it step by
step layer by layer and you can see grat
for me I was able to see you know
gratifying results with very little code
right away and then of course you can
add more and more and more as you go so
that's that's essentially it and you
know one of the things you know they
FEMA
uh redrew the flood inundation maps for
New York City so now my house is in a
flood zone when it wasn't before so I'm
interested in trying out this project on
uh on Manhattan next so okay so thank
you so much for for listening uh this is
how you can get in touch with me I'm on
my blog as outsiderdata.net
uh you can see the code on GitHub and
you know I love GitHub and I it's just
for me because I like I have a laptop
I've got a desktop I've got
a weekend house and I you know I can
share all my code and work on that stuff
wherever I am but also all of my work is
public and it's it's it's
ugly right because it's just it's just
for me I'm not writing for you I'm
writing for me but at my GitHub you can
see just everything I do in in R but I'm
a big believer in getting stuff out
there uh Dave Robinson
said something that really stuck with me
and it caused me to start blogging he
said look don't be embarrassed about
what you don't know and that you're that
you're not a professional data scientist
because the value of the code
that's on your computer is zero so as
soon as you put it out into the world to
for other people to share and see
is value increases infinitely more right
this is my Social Media stuff uh Ada
Babbage on Twitter and Mastodon my
homepage artstimus.com and on LinkedIn
Ace Steinmetz
so there you go
thank you thanks a lot for coming thank
you folks for online
so let me start this off of a virtual
question they'll ask some questions in
the room
um do you know where oh you come here
you're not done you're answering
questions do you know where the elevator
package gets this data from for the
elevations uh yes
um open elevation hold on let me go back
to the all the packages blah blah blah
it was like way in the beginning way in
the beginning way
uh open topography okay and that's good
worldwide data uh I haven't tried every
why everything in the wide world but so
far so good it does Ukraine okay and it
does everywhere in the United States but
for when I'm doing a United States Topo
work uh like this uh
uh like this Ray Shader thing
on the on the left I used USGS Topo data
so you can download historical
topographic maps from USGS that are
geospatial raster files so they have the
the pixels that you see here and the
elevation data as a layer yes
um then I guess a follow-up question
that elevator data is you passed in an
SF object and they took the bounding box
from that and just returned a raster
based on the bounding box yeah so you
just use you can feed when when the
function asks for a bounding box and a
lot you have to check this of course but
a lot of the functions will take are
actually looking for a so-called extent
object which is one of the
um
uh pieces of the metadata in a simple
features file so a lot of them when
they're asking for the extent or the
bounding box you can feed it the whole
simple features variable
and it will extract the extent from it
that's nice
cool do we have questions in the room
yeah getting all sorts of coordination
references
yes they can as well I'm I'm saying yes
because there's there's a standard
they're they're pretty standardized yeah
so you may run into one that's that is
very customer proprietary but it's
unlikely
near the poles it can get messy right
near the poles North and South Poles
things can get messy
yes can you please go back to the slide
where you just got saving the frames
yeah sure
okay do you have any guidance on about
how many frame teams we would want to do
or was that more of a automatic value
how many frames we would want to do
any guys well I just because we know
we're animating
um Rising Water by meter so how many
meters are we interested in however many
it took to create a really flooded area
so again just in the uh you know in the
interest of of truth I don't know what
the maximum height of the water level
was after the dam broke but I know that
the bottom of the dam is about eight
meters above sea level just
experimentally so that's why I saved
eight frames
and then I morph between it so there's a
smooth transition
so you'll just have to experiment I
could do more frames but it wouldn't
show you anything because I'm going in
integer steps meter by meter by meter
thank you so and so basically I said if
so I change so I took my elevation
Matrix and looped through that eight
times well and said you know if the
water level is you know at or below
the water level I'm interested in set it
to in well actually I had to go to minus
two not zero to to get what the uh
minus two just happened to be what the
completely unflooded
River delta looked like
and that's all race Shader right the way
the code is right now that's ratio
that's ratiator right that that uh base
map is the base map and then add overlay
add water add overlay
uh are
those three things are ratiator
functions uh and then save PNG is not
that's from the PNG package and Rave and
Ray render is how you make like the 3D
fly-throughs and that's different than
ratio it's like related but different
yeah race Shader calls a lot of Ray
render okay functions so it just wraps
it up in it's in some sense a wrapper
for Ray render that makes it more easy
to work with map data spatial data and
um uh like ggplot code things like that
but yeah Ray render when I do cute
little flyover stuff you know there I
use Ray render okay
and could you make sure you repeat the
question when he asks yeah
a nerd and so like you can do like
leaflet in a shiny but that doesn't
really scale well on your blog very well
do you know any tools that can reduce
JavaScript or just kind of be a publicly
accessible
well yeah so
um these rendering tools that I'm using
again I'm saving to PNG files right so
save PNG as you see here so obviously
once you once you do once you save it as
a static image
and all of these packages let you easily
do that you've got rather like more
interactive things and so on more
interactive well then you're then you're
still in the world of HTML
and
in this case I'm using our markdown or
its successor in particular quarto to
generate a uh a web page that has all
that interactivity so you have to have
HTML widgets if you're going to use have
interactivity now
you may be comfortable with JavaScript I
don't know JavaScript from a hole in the
ground but you know I do know our
markdown and quarto so if I save those
files those create the HTML widgets and
then you can save those those files and
there it's like I said it's converted to
HTML with um with I assume some
JavaScript elements in it but that's all
invisible to me and I don't care
so thank you by the way I've been having
a huge amount of fun with with quarto
which is the new publishing framework
from posit that that works with with
anything JavaScript python are it's just
super easy this this was a this is a
this is a reveal.js
HTML this reveal.js is what is
underneath all this HTML in here and I
don't know anything about that I just
said for set format to reveal JS and
voila we have a cool slideshow
and I you know I don't know how it works
just magic
other questions yeah all the way in the
back then we'll go to that
um
[Music]
work with those or things like
geopenders and python you have any high
level thoughts on just what R in
particular make easier compared to other
Alternatives and what R could do that
those couldn't do
yeah I'm sure what is that oh yes I am
going to repeat the question so
um any any thoughts on what R in
particular does in the geospatial
geospatial realm versus say python which
has geopandas well or qgis also or
what's that or qigis huge huge thank you
really the boy I'm it's getting late in
the day
um qgis well qgis is very much an
interactive tool for loading
manipulating and then saving GIS
workflows very powerful but it's not
while it does have I think a python
interface that you could go in and do
little Python scripts that do stuff in
qgis uh it's it's not strictly
programmatic it's more like Excel or
something like where you might do VBA in
it but it's you manipulate things
on the Fly and then save your projects
on python okay I I'm not well versed in
Python I assume geopandas is basically
uh a full featured package I don't think
there's a whole lot of you you can't say
or is better for this and python is
better for that on anything anymore
because pretty much the day somebody
releases a python package that gets huge
uptake there's an R version of it care
ass torch Psy kit all of that stuff all
is just as usable in the in the r world
so I think whatever vernacular you're
most comfortable with is the where
you're going to get the most work done
the only exception to that would be Ray
Shader I don't think there's a python
analog to that at all and that's just
tons of fun but otherwise I wouldn't you
know I'm sure the geospatial tools in
Python are essentially the same thing
just as just as convenient like again I
discovering simple features was a
miracle to me because again it just
makes it everything is so human readable
and easy to manipulate and I'm sure
geopandas is the same thing
yes you so oh that's that was a great
talk and could you uh could you rather
than ready that you're a model for
example can you get the actual satellite
image of the plotting and see your
mother yeah the short answer is yes I
haven't I haven't tried that
um there but if you Google around online
you can see uh satellite images of the
flooding I mean it's crazy the way this
war is being covered by satellite
imagery right so so you know something
gets blown up
today and two days later you see the
satellite imagery of the destruction on
telegram or wherever so you could get
any one of those I haven't done it but
you could look for those images and then
using qgis this is what I use qjs for
all the time geo-reference those images
so you basically
um there's a there's a so-called
geo-referencer tool in qgis that lets
you click on a picture on a on a point
on your let's say jpeg image and then
click on a point on the open street map
image and map that point
to the image and you do that 10 20 times
or whatever and then that that will
twist and and transform that jpeg image
so that it overlays perfectly on the map
and then you can save that as a
geospatial raster
and you could overlay that on your R
imagery very simply so but again the
geo-referencing feature of qgis is what
I use it for all the time
[Music]
qgis I think they are the web they are
corrected at different times
so
can you
properties that for example some
straight to data is collected in the
2019 and you use the geographic element
Elevate data is connected to 2020 can
use some online
time axis of the data
uh yeah you could I mean that would be a
manual process but so for instance I
mean this is
this isn't what you're so the question
is can you download different data from
different time frames and step through
that time through through time is that
what you're asking
you so in the in the top of your not
saying about the time so I'm so my
question is oh you feel you cannot align
the hind axis as well not just the
geography curve
so you are saying that oh you can do
some projection or other oh well yeah I
mean again I I hope I'm understanding
what you're saying properly but that is
one of the things that I would say
simple features is really uh really well
suited for because we've you know we
have you know however many rows of
geospatial data and we and each one of
those rows has some features like in
what we saw earlier was the name of the
street and the line that represented it
there's nothing stopping you from saying
if you've got multiple Road files
because roads change over multiple years
you could add time as another column in
your simple features data set
and step and filter you know again using
your usual
um data frame manipulation tools filter
by year
and create a frame you know save it as
an animation frame
each each year so it's it's super easy
to do if you already are comfortable
manipulating and adding columns and
filtering data frames
anything else another virtual one yes I
might need to repeat this Maps
Overture Maps yeah it's a coalition like
Microsoft Facebook and Amazon to compete
against Google and they seem to be
releasing like a lot of similar data to
open to open Stream app so I was
wondering if you knew about them if you
can compare them I guess you haven't yet
do I know about the Overture project no
this is the first time hearing of it
yeah
um but there's uh there's a lot of
different data sources besides open
street maps for mapping data not just
open street maps and it's
um they have a lot more things than
roads on open street maps so they've got
you know locations of businesses
um you can I've seen some code examples
where you say you can with just a few
lines of code say you know something
like Google Maps does very easily but
you do it programmatically say show me
all the hamburger restaurants in a five
mile radius of this particular point so
open street maps can do stuff like that
but again I haven't looked at Overture
at all
fire hydrants for insurance purposes
would there be any reason to use that
over so so he would just say I'm gonna
I'm repeating it so you were saying
Overture was good for finding fire
hydrants for insurance purposes well
so whatever Facebook purchased Maple
area in 2020 yes
probably going into it so the mapillary
data is probably going into Overture
yeah used it because it was another free
data source like they released it for
free
stuff is good
yeah it was Overture recently for a
personal project and can confirm it was
very easy in the data
okay over one endorsement for Overture
one and a half one and a half yeah okay
so I'll look at that thank you
anybody else have any questions at all
check online to see this anymore online
but anyone else have anything here
then I guess a big round of applause
a lot of fun good I'm glad I appreciate
the invite the the it came through about
to get you to give another talk again
soon we'll give you more notice yes uh
thank everyone who attended virtually
thank everyone who attended in person
those in person if you'd like to go to
the bar we'll probably go to the bar
it's usually just uh what's that the
Beer Authority right across the street
unless anyone knows a better bar
I'm taking suggestions you want to go
come with those of you virtually
can't come with us unfortunately but
we'll see you another time remember we
have the r government Conference next
month October 19th through 20th uh go to
rstats.ai gov to find out more don't be
late here's one of our speakers as I'm
pointing at him
um and also next month Meetup October
10th at NYU and that's everything great
take home the pizza people here because
we have a lot of it and see you at the
bar and see you next month the
technology worked my wife was watching
the live stream from Anguilla holy crap
that's awesome yeah nice I should pay
attention to everything you said yes I'm
sure nice nice well thank you everyone
see you next time
[Applause]